MATTHEW MCNULTY: Hi there.
[APPLAUSE]
So my name is Matthew
McNulty and this talk
is going to be
all about Polymer,
so this is sort of our
Polymer keynote, if you will.
So before yesterday, how
many of you, show of hands,
have heard of Polymer?
Excellent.
All right.
So you're going to be
excited because we've
got some new stuff to show
today that we didn't even
show yesterday.
And then if you haven't,
for those of you
that don't know
about Polymer, I'm
going to do a little bit
of an introduction first.
So Polymer is part of the
web platform team on Chrome,
and as part of the
web platform team,
it's our job to make
web developers like
you more successful and the
apps you build more awesome.
The Polymer team does that by
bringing app-like immersive
experiences to the web
on mobile and desktop.
So Polymer officially began
about three years ago, just
under, but it began a
little bit earlier than that
with the invention of Web
Components a few years
before that.
We've talked about Polymer at
I/O for a couple of years now
but we've always used
a lot of caveats,
like Developer
Preview and Pre-Alpha,
and basically whatever we
could make up to say please
don't judge just too harshly
because it's still baking.
So today, to the terror
of my engineering team,
those caveats are gone.
So today, we
introduced Polymer 1.0.
[APPLAUSE]
And Polymer is now
ready for production
and it's entirely
new in the last year.
So if you looked before,
we've rewritten it entirely
from scratch.
So we kept what developers
loved but made it much smaller,
faster, and simpler.
And I'm going to tell
you all about it,
Taylor's going to show you
it in use today across Google
and elsewhere, Eric's going to
deep dive into Google scale,
production applications
built with Polymer,
and Addy is going to show you
how you can get started today.
That's a lot to cover,
so let's dive right in.
So Polymer isn't simply a
better version of something else
out there.
It's not like things
that came before.
So that 1.0 after it has
a deeper meaning than just
a version number.
So it signifies
something totally new.
So starting out at
Google a few years ago,
we were given a
really bold mission
to do something totally
new and build on something
revolutionary and dramatically
change web development,
so to get right out on the
bleeding edge of standards
and start pushing and
vetting new concepts.
And from out here, looking
at the landscape of web
development, we see the
world a little differently
with a different perspective.
Web developers don't generally
have the freedom to spend time
out on the bleeding edge
because you've got stuff to do.
And browser implementers who
come up with the standards
aren't web developers.
And from this perspective,
web development right now
is pretty crazy.
Everyone's fighting
all the time.
So there's tons and tons of
frameworks and tons of choice
but it's all different and
none of it works together.
It's a complicated world
and everyone's fighting.
So all these frameworks
have an idea of components,
little bits of apps that can be
used in different applications,
but they're all different
and they don't work together,
and working together is the key.
So I can explain this a
little better with an analogy.
So we sit in the San
Francisco office of Google.
We're kind of lucky that
way, and it's right down
the street here on the Bay.
This is actually our view.
I took this picture
a couple months ago.
And ever since we moved
into this office, about 60%
of the casual
conversation in the office
has revolved around
container ships
because it's what we see going
by all day, the entire time.
And it turns out the
shipping container
is a really interesting thing.
So before shipping containers,
everything was custom.
You made a thing and if you
wanted to move a lot of them,
you built a pallet for it, and
at every stage of the journey,
everything was done by hand.
And to fix this, they
didn't standardize boats
or standardize trucks to be
exactly the same in silos.
They standardized the
containers and made
everything that carries
them able to carry
the same container.
And the same container
can go from truck
to train to boat all
without ever being unpacked
with maximum efficiency, and
this makes the whole system
work together, and
these boats can carry
an enormous amount of cargo.
So we actually looked it
up because we were curious
as to how much cargo-- what's
the value of cargo of every
ship we see go buy, and it turns
out on average about $1 billion
to $1 1/2 billion
and a half dollars.
So what's this got to
do with web development?
Building a web app today
is also really challenging.
It takes an enormous
amount of expertise
to get right, especially
across multiple platforms
and multiple form factors.
So the web isn't any less
capable than other platforms.
It's just a lot harder
to get exactly right.
It's really easy to get on
board but difficult to master.
So the answer to this
is Web Components.
Web Components fix
this the same way
that shipping containers did
as well, interoperability.
Let me explain what that means.
HTML works everywhere
in every framework.
If you stick a Button tag in
your code, it works everywhere.
If you build a button
in Angular or React,
it only works in an
Angular or React app.
The same goes for all of
the existing frameworks.
They're all silos and that's
been the state of the art.
That doesn't mean
that these are bad.
It just means that
Web Components
are a different thing.
So the Button tag works
everywhere that would be great,
but Button is pretty lame
and apps demand better.
Web Components introduce custom
elements, so no longer just
a button, but fancy buttons,
like material design buttons.
And not just fancy buttons,
but headers and drop downs
and switches and
sliders, everything
you need to build up into a
really cool app like the I/O
web app I'm pretty sure
every single one of you
used that was
written in Polymer.
And unlike fancy
custom elements you've
seen before, Web Components
are interoperable.
So existing HTML
is a set of tools
useful 20 years ago for building
documents, not applications.
Web Components now add
another layer functionality
above the platform but below
other frameworks, new elements
you can add and you
can use everywhere.
This dramatically
changes the web platform.
And it unlocks this future
of web development today
that we've been talking
about, a future where we all
work together.
You don't have to
roll your own UI
or choose from an array
of siloed frameworks.
You can pick from off
the shelf, from this ever
increasing collection of
custom bits and pieces
to build your app, or
even make your own.
If you build something awesome,
anyone can use it anywhere.
So Web Components
are this revolution.
Web Components are
the shipping container
that standardizes everything.
And Polymer is a library
for building Web Components
and makes it faster and
easier to build standard Web
Components you can
use everywhere.
So Polymer is different.
Polymer isn't a framework.
Let me say that again.
Polymer is not a framework,
and that's not some distinction
without a difference.
Polymer is not a framework
because the very premise
of Web Components is that
they are not a framework.
It isn't just here to
replace some other framework.
It's not about Polymer
versus something else
because Web Components
built with Polymer
can work with everything else.
So we've been saying this
about Web Components in Polymer
for a little while now, but
even if you listened before,
to those of you who
have seen it before,
there's reason to look again.
That's because Polymer
1.0 is brand new.
We spent the last
year rebuilding it.
So building something that the
biggest and the best web apps
can depend on demands
a really high bar.
About partway
through last year, we
realized we could do better
than what we have already,
so we rewrote a new Polymer,
a production ready Polymer.
It's one that maintains the same
great features and ergonomics
developers love most but
in a new package rewritten
with a laser focus on speed
and reduced complexity.
So let's take a look at how
we did, starting with speed.
So it's three times
faster on Chrome
than the previous version, four
times faster on mobile Safari.
So Safari is still slower
overall than Chrome
because it doesn't have
native Web Components
but it's a lot closer now.
In terms of code complexity,
1.0 is 35% less code overall.
That's only 42k gzipped,
including all the polyfills
and everything.
And in fact, thanks to a new
modular design, as little
as 19k can get you
started with Polymer.
That's really, really
small, and over 60% less
code than it was originally.
And all of this comes with
the same great features
that Polymer had before.
It sugars the underlying
Web Components syntax
and adds features to make them
easier and simpler to use.
It adds new features
to make it easier
to build whole systems
out of components.
This makes components
easier to click together
into more complex
components or even apps.
And 1.0 brings a
lot of new features,
but I'm just going to talk about
two of the bigger ones today.
So a lot of what
developers told us
they didn't like about Polymer
was actually the Shadow DOM
Polyfill, not Polymer.
You see this today
all over the web.
So the polyfill was technically
awesome but complex.
It was globally intrusive,
and if you weren't careful,
it could be slow on
mobile platforms.
And it was never actually
meant to be fast.
It was meant to be complete.
So we replaced it in
1.0 with a simpler shim
that we called Shady
DOM, sort of Shadow DOM.
So it uses Shadow DOM on
platforms like Chrome that
support it and a simpler,
less capable mechanism
on less capable browsers.
So it's not a
perfect replacement
in terms of API compatibility
like the Shadow DOM Polyfill--
it makes some trade
offs for performance--
but it's meant to disappear as
soon as other browsers ship Web
Components.
And the other major
new feature in 1.0
is theming and styling
with CSS custom properties.
So Web Components introduced
scoping to the DOM tree
and CSS was built assuming
a single unscoped tree,
and that's made the
intersection of CSS
and Web Components fit
together really oddly
with special selectors made to
crash Shadow DOM like Deep that
are clumsy and
actually really slow.
So custom CSS properties
are the answer
to this problem we've
actually been searching
for a couple of years now.
They allow the targeting
of nodes across boundaries
and even mix-ins of
sets of properties
that can apply to
specific nodes.
So Addy is going to talk more
about this in a little bit.
And even better, CSS
custom properties
are a standard and
already being implemented
across multiple browsers.
Mix-ins are a new part of
the proposal, that's new,
but Polymer 1.0
introduces a shim
for this emerging standard.
And 1.0 has got a number
of other, smaller features,
and most but not
all of the features
that Polymer had previously.
But Polymer itself is just
one part of the story.
So the existing web
platform is the basis
of all web apps today,
and now it's more capable.
We have this new layer
of Web Components,
and these components form a
new ecosystem on top of which
frameworks and apps exist.
So now when you
build an app, you
have a whole new set of
building blocks to choose from.
For whatever problem
you have as a developer,
there's an element for that,
and if there isn't, you
can use Polymer to build your
own so that all the developers
after you don't have to.
But what elements
are there and how
do you navigate this ecosystem?
So to answer that, I'd like
to invite onto the stage
Taylor Savage, product
manager for Polymer.
[APPLAUSE]
TAYLOR SAVAGE: All right.
Thank you, Matt.
So as Matt said,
my name's Taylor.
I'm the product manager
on the Polymer team
and I'm going to talk today
about some of the things
that you can build with
Polymer, namely elements.
First to step back a little bit.
Our mission on the
Polymer team is
to make it easy
for any developer
to create a high quality
application on the web,
and the raw material
that we use,
the raw ingredients that we use
to create these applications,
are elements.
Now, with Web
Components in Polymer,
we go from having a very small,
limited subset of elements
to just about anything
we can imagine,
and that's really,
really powerful,
but it's also a
big responsibility.
And as we know, the
quality of your end result
is going to be directly
reflective of the quality
of the ingredients
that you put in.
So this is why we
on the Polymer team,
in addition to the
library, have built
sets of high quality
elements for you
to use in your applications.
So previously, we had
two sets of elements.
We had the core elements
and the paper elements.
We recently renamed the core
elements to the iron elements.
They are the strong
building blocks
that you use for just
about any application.
And we also have
the paper elements,
which are the reference
implementation for material
design.
Well, today, we're going to
introduce a few new element
product lines.
The goal of each of
these product lines
is to solve a very
specific set of problems
that web developers
commonly run into.
So our first product line is
the Google Web Components.
So at Google, we have a wide
array of different services
and APIs that you could add
into your application that
are really, really powerful,
things like Maps and Analytics
and YouTube and Translate,
but they can also
be a little bit hard to use.
The APIs can be a
little bit finicky
and there can be a lot of
boilerplate to get started.
So with the Google
Web Components,
we've wrapped every single one
of these APIs as an element.
If you need to add a
Google Map to your page,
drop the Google Map
element onto your page.
If you need to get data
out of a spreadsheet,
drop the Google Sheet
element onto your page.
We've standardized the way
you interact with these APIs
with elements and we've
created kind of a Google SDK
for the web through
these elements.
The second product line
I'd like to talk about
are the Platinum elements.
So as you've probably heard
a lot at this conference,
the web has some really
amazing new primitives
that we've introduced that let
you do things that we've never
been able to do before
as web developers, things
like offline caching and
things like push notifications
with Service Worker.
And with the
Platinum elements, we
want to again bring these
really powerful features to you
in the easiest way to use
possible with elements.
So we've wrapped
Service Worker features
and all of these new
re-engagement features
on the web as elements.
If you want to drop a push
notification onto your page,
drop a Push
Notification element.
If you want to get
offline caching,
you can declaratively
set up offline caching
with a Platinum element,
and so much more.
These features that we as web
developers only six months ago
could only have dreamed about
are now just a single element
away.
[APPLAUSE]
And finally, the Gold elements.
So e-commerce is a really
hugely important part of the web
platform but it can
be hard to get right,
especially on mobile.
Those big, long checkout
screens were not
meant for a five inch device.
So with the Gold elements,
we've introduced a new set
of product lines specifically
to help developers build really
high quality check out flows,
so things like auto validating
credit card fields, auto
validating name input fields,
CVCs, expiration dates.
And with these, it
makes it really easy
to build a mobile
first check out flow.
So we have the Iron elements,
the Paper elements, the Google
Web Components, the
Platinum elements,
and the Gold elements.
Each of these solves a
specific set of problems
that developers run into when
building web applications.
And many times, that's
exactly what you want.
You have a problem and you
need a specific solution
to be able to fix that problem.
But other times, we just
want to be inspired.
We just want to come across
maybe a design we hadn't
thought about or a feature
or application that we
hadn't considered.
And we want our
element product lines
to help you do that
too, to help you just
be inspired by new things
that are available to you
on the web.
So to help with this, to help
with the problem solving,
and also to help with
just the inspiration,
we're releasing a brand
new element catalog
for all of these elements
where you can browse and find
and play with these elements.
In the catalog, you can
search for elements,
you can browse by element
product line, play with demos,
you can read element
documentation,
and you can even add
elements to a cart,
download the cart to use
directly in your application.
Our hope is that for
any feature that you
might want to create on
the web, that there's
an element for that.
And we think the idea of
related element product lines
is really powerful,
and what's great is
we're not the only
people that think that.
There are tons of companies
out there building
incredible elements
with Polymer,
and we'd like to highlight
a few of those today.
The first is Atavist.
So Atavist is a
publishing company
that recently released a brand
new platform for storytellers
to tell really engaging
stories on that web.
And the heart of an
Atavist story is text,
but it goes so far beyond that.
You can bring in all
kinds of different media
into your Atavist story,
things like movies and pictures
and video, but other
things like music
and maps and
charts, anything you
might need to tell just
a really engaging story.
And the web is a perfect
platform for that.
It's a perfect
platform for bringing
in different kinds of
media from all over the web
into one place.
But Atavist needed a
common way to refer
to these different components,
to these different blocks,
and the web has a great
language for that as well.
It's elements.
And so the Atavist
team used Polymer
to build each of these
different blocks and components.
It makes them really easy to
work into the Atavist platform
and it makes it really easy
for the team to build more.
It's a poetic use
of the web platform
and a really perfect
example of Polymer,
and it's a really just well
designed application to boot.
So we've talked about
creativity and publishing.
Now let's talk about enterprise.
So the Vaadin team has one
of the most popular Java
frameworks for building
enterprise applications,
and they're building now all
of their front end components
out as Polymer elements.
And with an enterprise
focus, the Vaadin team
focuses very specifically on
how to show big sets of data.
So they've built some
incredibly impressive elements
that I'd like to show off today.
The first is the V-grid.
So grids of data can
be really, really hard
to get right on the
web, so the Vaadin
team has done all of the
hard work for web developers.
They've built this
V-grid component.
It's got all the
features you'd expect--
lazy loading, multi select
rows, rows and columns,
and it's fully accessible.
Again, Vaadin team doing
the hard work of this grid.
And you'll notice that the
markup inside is just a table.
It's just what we'd
expect as developers.
It's the component
that makes the magic.
They also are
working on and soon
to release a set
of chart elements
for all kinds of
different charts,
similarly doing the hard work
to get this data visualization
right.
You can see markup
inside is very similar.
It's the element
that does the magic.
And finally, Salesforce.
So Salesforce wants to ship
and is shipping an SDK, an API,
for developers to easily
build applications using
the Salesforce platform, and
they want to make it as easy
as possible to leverage
the Salesforce information
and data.
So naturally, they ship
the Salesforce APIs
as Polymer elements.
You can use these Salesforce
elements, in addition to
other Polymer elements that
you might find or any element
out there, to just build
a really high quality
application using
the Salesforce data
and the Salesforce platform.
So we get asked a lot
on the Polymer team,
does Google use Polymer?
And of course, the answer
is a resounding yes,
and I'd like to talk about
a few applications that are
using Polymer at Google today.
The first is Translate.
So not that long ago,
the Translate team
wanted to build this
new product that
let community members contribute
different translations
to the Translate engine to make
it better and more effective,
especially for low
volume languages,
and so they built
Translate Community.
It's entirely material designed,
it looks and feels great,
it's got all the animations
and ripples that you'd expect,
and it's built entirely
out of the Paper elements,
and it's live today.
So this was built from start
to finish in just a few months
by two front end engineers
using the Paper elements,
and by using those
Paper elements,
it allowed those developers
to focus on just building
a really great application and
not on the nitty gritty of how
to implement material design.
The Play team also shipped
a brand new product
using Polymer Paper
elements, Play Music.
So the new Play Music front end
uses Paper ripples and Paper
toolbars and buttons.
Again, this allowed
the Play Music team
to focus on just building a
great application experience
and leave the nitty
gritty material design up
to the Paper elements.
The Play Properties
are also now working
on their own overarching
set of Polymer elements
specific to the Play
Properties so they
can use those across all
the different Play websites.
And finally, a lot of uses
of Polymer are still internal
but we'd like to
tease one today.
So this is a version of
the YouTube mobile front
end built entirely out
of Polymer elements.
And as you can see, they've
achieved a pretty cool
interface.
It's really snappy.
It's got all these great
animations and transitions,
and it's even got some
features that you'd never
expect to see on the web,
like this dragging video
to the corner of the screen
with the smooth playing
while the video plays.
Again, it's using
Polymer to build
a top notch, app-like
experience on the web.
So elements are pretty cool.
You can do a lot of really
cool stuff with them.
We're excited on
the Polymer team
to continue to build great
element product lines,
but we're even more excited to
see what you, the community,
can build, because the
sky is truly the limit.
So with that, I'll
hand it off to Eric,
who's going to talk a
little bit about taking
these elements to production.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC BIEDELMAN: Hello.
So I've been on the Polymer
team now for over three years,
ever since the project
started, and I've
talked to a lot of
developers in that time
about how to do things
in Web Components.
I get asked very
similar questions.
How do I create a single page
application in Web Components?
How do I do things like
internationalization?
How do I do lazy loading?
How do I do URL routing?
You can pretty much insert
anything curious Polymer
developers ask me
about, and how do I
do that thing in a web
platform using Web Components?
On the Polymer team, we
usually have this response,
"there's an element
for that," but I
wanted to really bunker down.
I wanted to experiment and build
some solutions myself, try out
and build apps on google.com,
productionize them,
see if this stuff was viable.
So last year, I got really busy.
Last year at I/O, I was
speaking about Web Components.
I got super lazy
in the summertime,
didn't do much on GitHub then.
But then if you fast
forward to the fall time,
I want to talk
about two projects
that we launched
on google.com that
are both written in Polymer.
So it's important to
note the things that I'm
going to be talking
about in this section
of the presentation, they don't
use the new, hot Polymer 1.0.
They use an older
version of Polymer.
So it's a little
slower, but we still
use this version to
productionize on Google.
All the hard work, totally
obsolete now, right?
Just kidding.
So the version of Polymer that
these components we created
is using doesn't matter
if it's an old version.
We can port it to a
new version of Polymer
because that's an implementation
detail of the component.
And we also created
a really nice set
of libraries for
the kinds of things
that we tackled during
these two projects.
So let's dive in.
Let's talk about
the first project.
Google Santa Tracker 2014
launched on Google.com
during the month of December.
If you've never seen Santa
Tracker, it's very cute.
So you can visit Santa's Village
during the month of December
and play a new game is
as each day goes along,
highly interactive.
You can change the sun,
change the moon, really mess
up the snowman, too.
So during the month,
again, each one
of these scenes,
as we call them,
launches, and each one
is a Web Component.
A couple examples of scenes.
It all works on touch.
It works on mobile.
Jam Band is one of my favorites.
It uses Web Audio API.
And this one's using WebGL.
Again, each one of those
scenes is a web component.
And of course, the
bread and butter
is when you get to the end.
The night before, you can
see Santa delivering presents
around the globe and
explore those cities.
So the team really took
"there's an element for that"
to heart for this project.
We created an element for Santa.
Santa-app is responsible
for orchestrating
the entire application.
It's responsible
for firing events
to analytics, starting
and stopping sound.
Inside of it, it has a bunch
of declarative web components.
So how do you do URL routing?
Well, you create a Web Component
for it, and that's what we did.
Santa has a URL router.
We tied that to an element
we created for lazy loading.
We created this
Lazy Pages element.
When a user selects a
new scene, we dynamically
load that scene, so
all the JavaScript,
all the CSS comes
along on the fly.
We were also super declarative
throughout the entire project.
So the loading sequence
when you load a new scene,
we're allowing the scene to
define its own background
image and its loading color,
so we're being declarative
with HTML attributes.
So that's Santa Tracker.
I want to focus the rest of my
time on the Google I/O Web App.
How many people have
used the web app
in the last couple of days?
A lot.
Great.
We call it IOWA, so I/O Web App.
It's a great state in the
Midwest where I'm from.
But if you hear me
say "IOWA," that's
what I'm referring
to, not the state.
So IOWA is a really good example
of a modern web platform.
It works on desktop, it
works on mobile really well.
You can see some of
this material design
take effect, where content
is first and foremost,
huge transition in
between pages and content.
If you click a video,
it goes to full screen,
both on desktop and mobile.
And so we pretty much
used every new API
possible on the web
platform for this project.
It's a single page
app, so you can
see I'm transitioning
between pages
and things are loading
dynamically on the fly.
Content slides out.
We also created a
custom element just
to render this WebGL 3D globe.
So WebGL-globe
allows you to search
across the globe for
I/O Extended Events
around the world.
Very cool stuff.
Like I said, this project
used every new API
you could possibly imagine.
So we touched all
the new stuff--
Service Worker, Polymer,
material design,
using some of the new
APIs that Google has.
Google Sign-in 2.0 is a new API.
We have an extensive
back end written in Go
in App Engine, web
animations and promises
for the material design effects.
I really want to highlight the
team that created this app.
It was in a very
short period of time,
and I think that's testament to
some of the reusable components
the Polymer team
is created for us,
but it wasn't a software
engineering team at Google
at all.
It was our Developer
Relations team,
and a couple people built this.
We didn't use any
special Google sauce.
We used all the
tools and techniques
that you have available to you
as a third party developer.
So how do you do
client side templating?
How do you do a single
page application
using Web Components?
Well, there's an
element for that.
But this was actually baked in.
This one's not a custom element.
This is the Template tag.
So a Template tag you
can drop in a page.
You can put some
markup in there.
In Polymer, we have
data binding features,
so you can see the
double mustaches.
And you can drop a bunch
of these on your page
ready to go when
you activate them.
In Polymer, we extended this
with this Ref attribute.
And so what happens is when
you change that Ref attribute
to an idea of another
template that's on the page,
that content gets used instead
of the original content.
So we said, this
is kind of cool.
We can change out
parts of the page
on the fly using this element
that we have available to us
now.
Let's not have all these
templates on a single page.
Let's break them out
into multiple pages
and load those dynamically.
So what we created
was a system that
used template plus HTML imports
to dynamically load content.
It's a different system
than Santa Tracker
but also a really cool one.
So if you load the Schedule
page in IOWA, what happens
is that the server
responds with a full page.
It has two
placeholder templates,
one for this main
masthead area where
the title of the page, and one
for the main content in blue.
So by default,
you load the page,
you get SEO friendly
static page.
The server just gives
you a bunch of markup.
Now, if you're
already in the app
and you navigate to
this page, we basically
take over and become a single
page application at that point.
So instead of
getting a full page,
we append this Partial
URL property to the URL,
and that says, server, give me
template partials for that page
instead of the full blown page.
You can see what
the server responds
with is that template
content for the masthead
and the template content for
the main area in the blue.
This is cool too because
the Template tag allows
you to define
JavaScript, so we're
allowing the page itself
to define its own load
handler, anything it needs to do
to set up itself and get ready.
This is a little bit of Polymer
1.0 code that does this.
Is a one liner in Polymer.
So you can think of this as
a dynamic script tag right
where you load that
on a page on the fly,
but instead of JavaScript,
we're loading an HTML file using
dynamic HTML imports.
So Polymer importHref
and you give it
the URL of the page of the
HTML file you want to load,
and you can see we're
appending that Partial URL
property on the URL.
So how did we achieve
material design?
Well, we really
studied the spec.
You see all the cool videos
in the material design
specification and it really
assumes zero latency.
And as web developers, we
know zero latency is just
not a thing.
You're going to be
dealing with jank.
You're going to be dealing with
network requests, a single page
application.
So how did we achieve all
these fluid animations
where cards are taking
over the screen,
pages are transitioning
in between things,
very cool ripple effects
that the material design
spec has in it?
What we did is we constructed
a logical animation sequence
using promises and
web animations.
So here's an example of
what happens when you
transition to new page in IOWA.
First thing we do is we run
this Run Exit Animation promise.
You can see what happens is
that the top masthead area
transitions between
colors of the pages
and that content slides out
and fades out at the same time,
so that's what
that promise does.
Next one we'll call
the import page method
that I just talked about.
This is where that network
request is actually fetching
the new content using Ajax.
Next thing that happens, once
that content is ready to go,
it's on the page already,
we run the enter animation.
And this animation basically
slides in the new content
and the content just below
it at 200 milliseconds, also
fades in with that
slight parallax effect.
And the last thing we
did, one these animations
and dynamic content's loaded, we
allow the page to run anything
it needs to so it can do
additional JavaScript.
It knows at this point that
all those animations are done.
So by using promises and
wrapping some calls in the Web
Animations API, we were able
to logically synchronize
all of this asynchronous
stuff that was going on,
whether it's CSS animations
running, whether it's
network requests being made.
And so that's how we achieved
some of the material design
effects in the app.
Offline first.
Really wanted to highlight
this feature in IOWA.
So Service Worker really
unlocks a whole new set
of capabilities
for web developers,
whether it's page
caching and being
able to do proper offline
push notifications
for the first time ever.
Something cool that
we're taking advantage
of in IOWA is fact that you
can intercept network requests.
So even though the user's
offline in our app,
we're stashing those
requests to Analytics,
storing those in Index
Database, and then we
replay those when
the user's online.
So we're not losing out that
valuable insight when the users
don't have a network request.
So first rule of Service Worker.
You have to let people
know about Service Worker.
What I mean by that is that
offline is totally new.
People don't expect
apps to work offline.
So if you load our app
for the first time,
we actually tell you that.
We want to you to know as a
user that this thing is going
to work, so we
show a little toast
that says, "future visits
will work offline."
The second thing you
have to deal with
is what happens if you're
at a flaky Wi-Fi connection
in a conference or you
go into Airplane mode?
Well, you should be able
to work offline as well.
So in IOWA, we detect that
and we send a toast that says,
hey, don't worry.
Changes you make
to your schedule
are still going to work
while you're offline.
So you can browse the
schedule even though I'm
in Airplane mode here.
We can actually navigate to new
pages because all of the pages
are pre-cached, all
the important URLs,
even though I haven't
visited them before.
So I can navigate to another
page, the Schedule page.
I can even try to
bookmark a session.
Of course, I'm offline.
That's not going to work,
but we'll tell the user that.
We'll store that information
in Indexed Database,
and then when
they're back online,
all that information is going
to be sent to our service.
All that stuff you
just did totally
will just work and will
inform the user that it did.
Last API I want to talk
about is Notifications, also
thanks to Service Worker.
If you haven't seen a web page
send a notification before,
it's a new feature.
That's totally all right.
This is what they look like.
So a proper
notification integrated
at the Property System level,
whether it's on desktop
or whether it's on mobile.
And your app doesn't
have to be open,
as seen in the screenshot.
You can still get
a notification.
So first rule of this new
API, you have to let users
know what's going on.
So if you visit our
site in an app that
doesn't support notifications,
the UI is pretty plain,
the Settings panel doesn't
have much going on,
the main page doesn't have
any special call to actions.
If you visit in a
browser like Chrome 42,
we actually adapt
our UI, we feature
detect that you
have notifications,
and we give you the option to
toggle on and off notifications
across the site.
We explain what that feature
is going to give to you,
and we can also enable other
features like set a reminder
for when Google I/O starts.
That button sends
a notification.
We carefully constructed
this notification experience
because we know that
users probably have never
gone through this
flow before so we
wanted to get it right in IOWA.
So if you try to
bookmark a session,
say you want a reminder
when the keynote happens,
we basically have
to log you in first.
You have to go through
our OAuth flow.
We have to know who to
send the notification to.
Once that's done, we can prompt
the user's browser permission.
You have to enable this
feature at the browser level.
And once that's done,
the user is allowing
us to send them notifications.
We'll tell them that that thing
was added to their schedule
and that they'll receive a
notification when I/O starts.
What happens when
users disable this?
They don't want to be sent
notifications from our app.
Well, in this case, we'll try
to do the same exact thing,
but of course, we'll modify
our messaging in that case.
We'll say, hey, that thing
was added to your schedule,
but maybe you want to learn
more how to enable this feature.
We think it's a great feature.
It's very useful to be
reminded when the I/O starts,
so we give them a link
to say how to change
this in the browser level.
So sending notifications,
super easy.
Add an event listener
for the push event.
You give it a title, you
give it a body in JavaScript,
and once you call the Show
Notification function,
that's the thing that actually
shows the notification
in the browser.
In I/O, we also are listening
for the notification click.
We want to reengage
users back to the site
from this notification.
So by doing, that we construct
a URL to their Schedule page so
they can see what's
changed in the schedule.
And pro tip, we're using
analytics here as well.
We want to track how many
people actually reengage
from that click so we know
if this feature is useful
and people are using it.
So I know that was really fast.
That's six months'
worth of work.
Both of these apps are still
up on their Google.com URLs.
They're built using Polymer.
They're open source today so you
can check them out on GitHub.
I'm going to throw it
over to Addy Osmani.
It's his first Google I/O.
Please give him warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
ADDY OSMANI: Hey, guys.
My name is Addy Osmani.
I work on developer
tooling for Polymer.
So the other week,
my friend had a baby
and I thought I'd
do something nice,
like maybe draw a
sketch of their baby.
So I went to Google.com
and I looked up,
how do I draw a baby?
Now, if you take a look
at most of the tutorials
for drawing a baby, they start
off a little bit like this.
Just draw a circle
and you'll be fine.
Now, once you see this,
you're like, I can do this.
This is pretty achievable.
And with all the hope in
the world in your eyes,
you scroll down to step two.
You're like, oh, come on.
I can do this.
This is going to be great.
And then you get to step two,
and when you get to step two,
it looks like this
baby is mocking you.
This isn't setting
you up for success.
You want better rails
than that because when
your getting started experience
looks a little bit like this,
the end product looks like this.
This is more like what
I would end up drawing.
Now on the Polymer team,
we wanted to do better,
so we took a look at
all of the work we've
been doing over the last year
in projects like the Google I/O
app, Google Web Starter Kit,
and the Google Santa Tracker.
And we took all of
our learnings and we
put it into a brand new project
that we're releasing today.
We're calling it
Polymer Starter Kit.
Now, Polymer Starter Kit is
an opinionated starting point
for building ambitious
apps using Polymer.
It looks a little bit like this.
You can go and download it
today on developers.google.com
in the brand new Tooling
section we've got there.
Let's dive into what Polymer
Starter Kit comes with.
Now, Polymer Starter Kit
comes with first class support
for material design.
When you're trying to
build a mobile web app,
there are few specific
pieces you always
end up needing,
things like toolbars,
header panels, all
of that awesomeness.
Now, Polymer Starter
Kit comes with support
for routing and
multiple views as well.
Earlier, Matt talked
about our brand
new theming system using
CSS Custom Properties.
Now, everybody's
got a color scheme
that they love using, and
using CSS Custom Properties,
you can easily go and re-theme
your entire application
in just a few lines of code.
This is a really,
really powerful system.
We think it's going to make
it super simple for you
to customize your apps.
Google is really big on mobile,
and with Polymer Starter Kit,
we wanted to make
sure that you have
good rails for the
mobile web, which
is why we include first class
support for things like Meta
Theme Color, so colorizing
the address bar,
and Web App Install Banners
so your users can stay
engaged with your application.
That's already set up for you.
We also include good defaults
for icons cross-device.
So whether you're on Android,
iOS, or Windows phone,
you've got good defaults
there that you can go and then
customize.
Now this year, the
material design team
published their brand new
guidelines on adaptive design.
This builds on
responses and tries
to look at how we can customize
interactions that also
work great depending on
the context and the device
that we're on.
So what are Polymer doing there?
Well, the first thing
we're looking at
is how we can improve
support for responsiveness.
The material design
guidelines now
give you good guidelines around
media queries and breakpoints,
so Polymer Starter Kit includes
all of these defaults set up
for you.
Now, these defaults
are just one set
of breakpoints that work well
for us based on the devices
that we support, but
you can go in and easily
customize them for your needs.
How many people
here love templates?
You guys like templates?
Everybody likes templates.
I love templates because they're
a little bit like a coloring
book.
You can go in and
very easily start just
putting in your
content and building up
your app, which is why with 1.0,
we're also introducing a brand
new set of templates
for your applications,
things like navigation
card layouts,
navigation list details for
building things like contact
apps, as well as
wider card views.
Now, this is only a small
subset of the templates
that are available today.
Now earlier, Eric talked about
the importance of offline.
In 2015, the reality is if
your app doesn't work offline,
you really don't have a
good mobile web experience.
The good news is the
Polymer Starter Kit
is offline first by default.
You load an application built
using Polymer Starter Kit up,
you go into Airplane mode,
go offline, load it up,
and you can still access
your entire application.
This is with zero
configuration necessary.
It's already set up for you.
Go in, navigate any of your
routes, and the content all
still works.
Now, when it comes
to Service Worker,
it's a fantastic set of
APIs, but there's still
a lot of configuration
required to get this set up.
Thankfully, there's
an element for that.
We dive into the
Polymer Elements Catalog
that Taylor was
talking about earlier.
We can see that we've got
access to Service Worker
Caching with the
Platinum set of elements.
So here, we're declaratively
registering our Service Worker
and setting up caching strategy
in just a few lines of code.
Here, I'm saying that
my caching strategy
is going to be
network first and just
passing in a list
of the files that I
would like to be pre-cached.
Let's talk about
productionizing apps.
Now, we all know
about the importance
of the build process.
A build process is a
promise to your users
that you're going to make
sure that whatever you're
shipping down the line is as
small and as fast as possible.
Now, on the Polymer team,
we're big fans of Gulp.
it's a fantastic
streaming build system.
And so out of the
box, we include
support for unit testing using
a brand new version of Web
Component Tester, quality
and testing, minification
using tools like Vulcanize,
and cross-device reload using
Browser Sync.
Now, Browser Sync is
particularly awesome
because it means
that if you're making
any changes to your Polymer
Starter Kit application,
you'll get to see those
changes propagate across all
of your devices at once.
It'll also synchronize things
like clicks and scrolls,
making it really,
really pleasant
to cross-device development.
Now, you've seen
Polymer Starter Kit,
but you might be wondering,
well, this is great,
but has anyone actually tried
building a real app with it,
something that's nontrivial?
So let's dive into
our chemistry set.
We've got a lot of elements
that are available.
Let's see what they can do.
What if we were to put
together an application then
we would use on the go,
something like an RSS reader?
So we did.
This is Paper Reader.
It's built using
Polymer Starter Kit.
It allows you to log
in using your Google
account, your GitHub
account, any service
that you have an
existing account with,
and you can go and
view all the stories
that you love following along.
Here we can see there's a ton
of I/O news out at the moment.
I can also go and
favorite feeds.
I can set feeds to
be read or unread,
and all the actions
that you would expect
to see in a normal RSS reader.
Now, for this type
of application,
one of the first things
you need is the ability
to pull in Google Feeds.
Thankfully, there's
a Google Feeds API,
and I'm glad to say that
there's an element that as well.
The Google Feeds element,
which declaratively
allows you to go
and say, download me
this particular RSS,
Atom, or Media RSS feed,
to specify the URL and the count
of entries you'd like returned,
and it can go and
help you very quickly
add content to your page.
Now, I mentioned the
idea of favoriting
inside this application
and setting something
to Read or Unread.
That requires a back
end of some sort.
Now, on the Polymer
team, we love
using Firebase,
which is why there's
a brand new set of elements
aside the Google Web Components
product catalog for
Firebase as well.
The Firebase element allows you
to authenticate using Google,
GitHub, and other services.
So here, for example,
in a few lines of code,
I'm connecting up to a Firebase
instance, setting a provider,
so I want to use
my Google account,
and this just allows
me to authenticate.
I can then use other elements
in this set to get and set data
from Firebase, too.
So here, I'm just
connecting up to an instance
and I'm able to loop over
that data and just output
it to the page.
We talked about the
importance of offline.
Here I've got offline and
Airplane mode in Paper Reader.
I'm going to refresh
the page and I'm
able to see all of my stories.
I'm able to browse through
stories I haven't seen before.
I'm able to go in and
view individual entries.
And this just means
that as I'm on the go,
I can easily use this stuff.
And there's, of course, an
element for this as well,
the Platinum Service Workaround,
as we showed you earlier.
Now, push
notifications are huge.
They allow your users
to opt in to getting
timely messages about
things that they care about.
Here, we've got Polymer Starter
Kit receiving a notification
about new stories.
I can go in just tap
this notification,
and I can view any
of the new stories
that I haven't read just yet,
and they'll just show up.
Now, there's an
element for this, too,
the Push Notification Platinum
elements, which declaratively
allow me to set up
push notifications
and trigger them inside my
application's life cycle.
In just a few lines of
code, we get something
that's really, really powerful.
So we've seen
Polymer Starter Kit.
It comes with
components, layout,
theming and build
tools, everything
you need to get started.
So you're in the driving now.
You've got a whole
lot of elements
available at your disposal.
There's an element
for many things.
What are you going to build?
With that, I'd like to
hand it back to Matt.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW MCNULTY: So
for the last two years,
Polymer has been about promise--
the promise of Web Components,
the promise of
interoperability, the promise
of this declarative renaissance.
Now that promise is reality.
Web Components have been
shipping in Chrome for a year.
There's a brand new, production
ready Polymer out today.
Google is using Polymer,
and Taylor showed you
a selection of major Google
properties using it today,
like YouTube, Play
Music, and Translate,
and there's a whole lot more.
Third parties are using
Polymer in production
today, like Salesforce,
Atavist, and Vaadin.
The Santa Tracker and I/O
Web App are offline enabled
and totally awesome,
and Polymer Starter Kit
can get you started today.
And this is just the beginning.
So we've got a lot more
features coming at a rapid pace,
ones we had to leave on the
cutting room floor for 1.0,
as well as more product
lines and elements.
For the very latest
and to learn more,
go to polymer-project.org
or our Slack channel,
where you can talk
to the team itself.
And we're almost out of time,
but we've got so much more
to show that we almost need our
own conference just for Polymer
and the web.
[APPLAUSE]
And there's an element for that.
Oh wait, sorry.
There's a conference for that.
So join us for the Polymer
Summit on September 15
in Amsterdam.
[APPLAUSE]
That's a picture of the venue.
It's this awesome
venue on the water.
So join us for a full day
of learning about Polymer
and cutting edge web development
from the people who know it
best, the Polymer Chrome teams.
So we'll have more info
on that in the next month.
There's a bit.ly link on
there, bit.ly/polymer-summit,
if you want to register
for information today.
Just for a brief moment
before we conclude,
I'd like to take a moment
to thank the Polymer
team for making today possible
with a whole lot a late nights
and weekends, especially
lately, even last night.
So please join me
in thanking them.
[APPLAUSE]
And more importantly, be
nice if you find bugs.
So that's all the time we have.
Thanks and enjoy the
rest of the show.
We have to get out of
here really quickly,
but if you find us out there,
we can answer questions.
Thanks.